Kanye West who lost Fortune after
anti-semitic tirade
says he likes Jewish people again that's
kind of good news
this is an Instagram post yeah
Nick Fuentes was paid apparently thirty
thousand dollars by Kanye West
presidential campaign and that's a story
that just came in when is this that's
yesterday the hill so let me read this
story to you and see what your thoughts
are on this so uh Nick Fuentes was paid
30k by Kanye West presidential campaign
Federal Election Commission filings
revealed that 2020 presidential campaign
of rapper Kanye West was a paid
far-right activists and white
supremacist Nick Fuentes over thirty
thousand dollars for uh uh archival
services and a travel reimbursement
according to data from a Federal
Election Commission he launched uh a
long shot run for president 2020
alongside former president Donald Trump
despite openly being a trump supporter
and earned about 60 000 votes on
Election Day Fuentes has been labeled a
white supremacist by the justice
department and is known for his racist
racist anti-semitic rhetoric Connie has
also come under Fire for anti-Semitic
what are your thoughts on the story
um I knew that Fuentes was working for
him I think we all kind of saw that
break a few months ago um Fuentes is an
absolute monster like truly I think I've
seen a few of his Clips
um explaining in terms of like cookies
in an oven how 6 million Jews could not
have possibly perished in the Holocaust
that's just the beginnings of the things
that he says so he's
absolutely just despicable I don't want
to know how we got to Kanye I don't know
what happened to Kanye I was a giant fan
um of Kanye's growing up and up until
recently uh listen to his music all the
time I loved skating to it and working
out to it and really yeah he was kind of
like the underdog inspiration in his own
way as well always yes I've Loved Kanye
forever so very disappointing um I
launched a Holocaust Education project
in honor of this whole situation called
uh you can find it educate kanye.com but
yeah it was really disappointing I think
he's going through something because
normal people do not not only want to
associate with Fuentes but want to hire
him to make him president so it doesn't
make a lot of sense I think if
something's off or sick then we should
just let him get help but do you think
Connie can do anything to uh because
apparently this whole story about him
watching Jonah Hill you know whatever 21
Jump Street and kind of changed my mind
like Jude like Jewish people again all
this stuff and this was a story about a
month ago or three weeks ago do you
think you know he can do anything to get
back to who he was before or is this
a permanent career you know done
decision that's going to ruin him for
years and years to come
he can come back hey Erica loves another
dog but I think people love when people
grow up apologize take responsibility
and move on and I think this is a very
easy thing to apologize for you know
there's no reason he can't say hey
really was going through something had
no idea the garbage that was coming out
of these people's mouths I apologize and
I'll visit Holocaust Museum I'll focus
on writing music and making amends and
take it from there one day at a time is
it kind of like if he wrote a song
instead of Jesus walked he says Jesus
never walked
to see what happens so so there is a
possibility that in the future you could
figure skate and listen to his music
again
yeah I mean possibly that's a tough one
you don't sound committed to it he was
he's known for his music he's not known
for politician Kanye West so I will
always admire his music okay Adam any
thoughts on this one yeah of course Nick
Fuentes Nick Fuentes specifically
um well
I just covered a story that he did with
my friend Pearl uh pearly Davis pearly
things massive YouTuber
um in the manosphere red pill space and
she invited him on the show and listen
when you uh when you play stupid games
you win stupid prizes and you sit down
with a guy like Nick Fuentes who is 24.
and now he's the expert on the Holocaust
right okay uh by the way it's
interesting that Kanye is able to thread
the needle of because uh white
supremacist anti-semite so it's like
Kanye will you know he'll tune out the
anti-semitic stuff I'm sorry tune out
the anti-black stuff but just kind of
focus on the anti-semitic stuff it's
like I know you hate blacks and Jews and
dogs but I'm just going to focus on the
Jewish part with you to their uh Nick so
uh Nick I think actually reached out
what was the situation Rob so I
basically responded to Pearl and I was
basically like look Pearl stay in your
lane you know if you want to be in the
dating red pill space you know why get
into debates over the merits of slavery
or the accuracy of
slavery and the Holocaust it's like
what's gonna what's the benefit for your
specific career do you know what this
girl is Pearl Davis I don't know okay
I'm sure you've seen her online take a
picture but I basically was like you
know your reputation is who you are even
if it's not who you are so Nick you ever
seen this girl
oh yeah she's like okay gotcha
um so Eve and I think Nick said hey I'm
not a white supremacist what was the
response well Nick's Camp reached out
and they wanted to see if you'd be
interested in sitting down with them um
the the quote was he's being smeared as
a white supremacist by Adam uh but I am
one of many examples of proof to the
contrary as I am a black man and this
was his uh middleman and what is one
says what he's that's a Latin last name
right he's Latino and he's okay and he's
just saying outlandish yeah well
it's not like I put the word white
supremacist out there you have Wikipedia
the guy Wikipedia it's the first thing
the American white supremacist political
commentator yeah so all I'm doing is
reading I'm not defending the guy at all
whatsoever but be careful when you're
the you know sane just because uh
Wikipedia says something about somebody
that that's who they are that's not how
I judge it what what has happened is if
these stories are surrounding you
there's a reason for for it uh some of
it is probably because you're trying to
get eyeballs and I saw him I think in
one clip if this is the same guy that he
was following Ben Shapiro while he's a
crossing the crossing the street with
his kids I think is is it the same guy
okay listen if you're doing that to get
the eyeballs great uh it's you work them
it's working for you people are talking
about you but there's certain things you
know I don't know if you want certain
things to be your identity out there so
maybe you can come on a podcast yet you
guys can talk to each other look maybe
I'll bring him down to the Holocaust
Museum in Miami Beach and we'll sit down
and have a cup of coffee right there or
we can go to the Holocaust museum in
Washington DC and let's see if that's
something that he'd be open to maybe
you'd like to join us sure so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]